hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb MB and
I'll be your driver on this journey so
today was a pretty exciting day at the
Chess Club we had the first round of the
first leg of the grand chest tour the
first three rounds actually it's a rapid
event going on on the Ivory Coast in
Africa featuring you know super strong
players such as the world champion
magnus carlsen Hikaru Nakamura US
Champion
Maxine B Sheila Grove as well as
numerous other players and so what we
have going on at the club is we're
actually giving commentary over this
event going on you know halfway across
the world and so I thought we I'd give a
little bit of an intro to our
commentators for this event and so we
have some really talented players
actually doing commentary for us you
know we're used to kind of yessir jenna
maurice those three in tandem doing
doing most of our commentary but we
actually have some really strong really
talented players and so i thought i'd go
over some of their best games some some
games that they've won so actually here
one of the players in the tournament
magnus carlsen was playing one of the
commentators pillai ta and why is this
relevant to you know players under 2000
was a question I was just asked before
we got started here and I think there's
a few reasons one of the best ways to
get exposed to new ideas learn new ideas
about chess is to watch these
broadcasted you know coverage over these
huge super GM events because very often
these commentators are not commentating
for GM's they're not trying to explain
everything at the Super GM level they're
making it so that players at our level
or players you know even more beginners
level than you know where we're kind of
at can understand the games and
understand what's going on and learn a
little bit about the positions so yeah
I have once allow those common types yes
so it can definitely depend on the
tournament the this is a rapid event so
it's a little bit more fast place and
there's less time with you so yet you
know it can be tough some commentators
are geared towards more advanced players
some are less advanced but I think
definitely just by surrounding yourself
and by surrounding yourself and in
commentary and stuff you know you do
pick up on certain ideas if you're
really paying attention there are ideas
being thrown out there that you can kind
of apply to your own games and as far as
what we're going to do tonight this
isn't just an intro of course these are
high-level games and even weaker players
can learn a lot just react of analyzing
games even if it's a position that
they're not really familiar with that
want to show up in their games even just
going through the process of analyzing
and calculating and thinking about
putting yourself in the shoes of these
strong players can definitely help your
chess ability so let's jump into it here
let's let's see how this game went we
went with one c4 so the English opening
Yannick responded with Knight of 6 with
Sun Knight c3 c5 Knight f3 d6 g3 b6 so
this is kind of an interesting opening
choice for black here what do you think
his plan is going to be moving forward
for black what does blacks plan going to
be moving forward yeah
Bishop to e2 Castle so yet to d7 so yeah
these these are the these are the the
common ideas b6 is kind of telegraphing
or you want to put the bishop on to b7
this bishop often comes here and then
black expands in the center and this
knight can either come to to d7 for c6
so yeah it can be tough to get this d5
break-in but this is kind of what black
is playing for and so one thing to look
out for though is this interesting
relationship between this Bishop on b7
and this Bishop on g2 this is something
that has been touched on before I think
I don't know if I've mentioned it in one
of my lectures but who does it usually
favor black with the bishop on b7 or
white with the bishop on g2 and why do
you think that is so you think of favors
black because the knight is pinned
any other ideas so yet not even the
position altogether but I'm just talking
about this relationship between these
two bishops sure so K in general can be
hard to break through did you have
anything to add
so yeah in an ideal world black is
hoping to trade off these bishops right
and then White's King usually White's
going to Castle kingside
after playing Bishop g2 then White's
King is gonna be a little bit weak
because of his light squares that he's
weakened with this g3 move but actually
in general this relationship is going to
favor white and the reason for that is
certain tactics that arise just because
of these bishops so let's just play a
couple moves here let's say Bishop g2
this should be 7 and then castles so why
does this favor white well it's actually
pretty simple White has only played
natural developing moose
I played Bishop g2 any castled and black
played the natural Bishop d7 but now the
key difference here is that white's
bishop is always going to be defended by
the king in a very natural state you
know white doesn't have to commit a
piece to defending the bishop it's just
going to be defended and black's Bishop
is for the moment undefended and if he
does want to defend that bishop he's
gonna have to waste time with something
like rook to b8 or like Queen to c7
which might not be terrible moose but as
long as this bishop remains undefended
there are always going to be tactics
that black has to look out for and
that's gonna kind of prevent him from
doing certain things that he might want
to do so there's always going to be
these potential moves with the knight
potential breaks with d4 when the knight
moves and then there's a key tempo on
this b7 bishop and so black really does
have to be a little bit careful when it
goes in for this relationship because
like I said it usually does tend to
favor white due to the fact that this
bishop is just naturally defended but
let's see what happened in the game so
Bishop g2 did was played we slept Bishop
e7 and castles simply Bishop e7 so you
know just because there are potential
tactics doesn't mean there are there's
anything right away so you know why it
doesn't have the ability to make use of
this just yet we saw b3 so white decides
to fee and cut out the other Bishop
castles they should be 2 and d6 so why
not defy v' what do you think what
stopped black from going for this very
natural break any ideas yeah so there
are a variety of things that white can
do here but the main thing to take note
of is the fact that now this Bishop you
can kind of see why it's not so
favorable for black because you know
this bishop is hanging and they're
always going to be these ideas of
something like Knight to e5 or maybe
takes first and then 95 and this bishops
gonna be undefended
so this pawn is going to run into some
nasty pins and so d5 is just a little
bit you know too much for black really
he's he's got to kind of consolidate a
little bit more get more of his pieces
activated before he can start playing in
the center and opening things up like
this so that's why we saw d6 and so you
know like I said this is part of the
thing where you can take these ideas
from these high level games you can see
what they do and then if you try to
understand why they did it so if you try
to understand why black didn't play d5
and chose d6 then you find things you
can start applying to your own games
right I'm sure this is something at
least somebody in the class here it has
seen before
from either side maybe and you you can
learn things about you know the kind of
the relationship of these bishops and
how to kind of apply these ideas to your
games but ok let's keep going
d6 black or white actually chose to
break in the center now with d4 we saw
pond tix
and Knight takes
yes oh wait actually does allow black to
trade off these bishops which is what
black was hoping for in exchange white
does get something in return right white
managed to break through with d4 and now
what do you think the natural follow-up
is is going to be for white let's just
play one more move for black Queen see
it so what does white want to do now how
does he prove that he got something in
exchange for giving up this lights grade
bishop yeah yeah so an eventually for
definitely so white gives up this Bishop
but in exchange she's going to have a
little bit more central space and that's
where White's going to try to prove his
advantage meanwhile black has gone for
kind of a different idea here blacks
idea you might know this as the hedghog
structure or it's similar to some
Hedgehog positions and blacks ideas
basically he hasn't made any weaknesses
which you might call d6 weak but really
it's only a true weakness if white can
kind of attack it pretty easily and the
only way for white to really attack it
is by playing some moves like this which
okay maybe I misspoke it is kind of a
weakness but the idea for black is to
eventually break through in the center
with something like d5 or something like
b5 and then d6 won't be as weak and he
can activate his pieces so those are
black's ideas and white's idea is simply
to try to use the central space
disadvantage maybe you'll see an F pawn
come forward to try and attack blacks
King and he's going to claim that okay I
have more space my pieces have more
squares that's where my advantage will
come from and so let's see how that
played out
we did see e4 right away that's really
the only way for white to play here
Knight to c6 rook to C one we saw Knight
takes d4 so it's a very common strategy
and you see it in these super G M games
so you see it at games of all levels
when you have less space when your
pieces have less squares a great thing
to do is to trade off pieces so you can
use your remaining squares for your
remaining pieces so you know black plays
very simply right he just plays knight
c6 getting develops and then trades off
this piece
which really wasn't doing a whole lot on
c6 for a very strong knight on d4 so the
queen takes d4 we saw queen - b7 simply
getting off the back rank right and so
black is not doing anything spectacular
right he's just simply developing his
pieces following opening principles and
playing to his eventual plan right this
queen supports the two key squares of d5
and b5 supporting those eventual breaks
we start work to D 1 and now a6 so this
prevents white from you know jumping
into any b5 squares and you know again
prepares this b5 idea so this is one of
those games where there weren't crazy
tactics flying around that you have to
be 2,500 2,600 2,800 to see blacks just
playing simple chests following the you
know good rules the good principles of
chess and that's something everybody
here can do we saw Bishop a3 so white
does try and prove that this pawn is
going to be a little weak black simply
brings the rook to the center and
defends it nothing spectacular Queen to
d3 we saw rook to d7 so this is you know
kind of a fluid move gives black a lot
of options he can double up here you can
still bring this rook to one of these
other files that he so chooses but it
just gives black a little bit more more
choice in the matter
Queen f3 and now we saw an interesting
move which was Bishop to f8 this was
kind of another idea
with rook to d7 as Bishop to f8 so what
was stopping black from playing bishop
f8 here right away why did he have to
include this Rick d7 idea
Oh
yeah that's right yes so it's a good
idea but you know of course it is pinned
yeah but yeah I mean you're along the
right track is so yeah I think black was
just worried about eventually five ideas
maybe throwing in something like King to
g1 or not probably not Queen to f3 first
but probably something like King to g1
or f3 and followed by e5 and so and yeah
so I don't think there's something
immediate which there might be that I'm
just totally missing
but in general it's good not to set
yourself up to fail right if you're
worried about eventual tactics why not
prevent those rather than you know
having to think about them constantly in
every turn so that's why you know you
play simply direct to d7
now the snipe defends this rook so
there's never gonna be any tactics there
Queen to f3 excuse me and now I go ahead
and he goes ahead and plays a mission f8
what continues with rook to d4 and okay
so what do we thinks going on here
what are both sides kind of well let's
start with what White's intending to do
in the next couple moves yeah White's
simply going to that you know double up
on the d6 pawn possibly even triple on
the triple on the d6 pawn with something
like yeah something like Queen e6 maybe
Queen f4 although you want to want to
hang five so probably not and he's also
looking to play e5 at some opportune
moment meanwhile black has a couple
options there's a couple ways he can
play this position right would you want
to play something like rook to d8 maybe
and just defend this pawn
okay so yes so that's right so you
should be thinking about these pawn
breaks for black on every turn trying to
calculate if they work now what you need
to do to prepare them and so there's
really no point to playing rook a to d8
here so the moves you need to be
thinking about are b-52d
and d5 because the black and achieve
either of these he'll definitely have
equalized and i mean you're playing the
world champion use 2850 you're happy
with the quality right especially with
the black pieces so let's think about it
what's stopping b5 what do we think when
it might happen winter whites choices
after b5
see five so yeah I see if I would be
interesting actually I don't think you
have quite enough support to play it yet
I think well I could simply capture yeah
II five Wow so yeah B five let's look so
so e 5 so it's it's an interesting line
an interesting line
definitely so let's try to think through
it so b5e five let's take stock of
what's happening so there's this kind of
conflict between the queens but although
both are defended right now
and so this Knight is hanging this pawn
is attacked and maybe if the Queen trade
does happen this pawn on d5 might be
hanging so if I think through it simply
I'd like to keep this defender on my
beep on so my most natural move is
actually just going to be to take here
so I take here maybe Rick takes d7 now
my Queens hanging if I take with the
night so all I have to play Queen takes
d7 and now at the end of everything it
looks as though I've simply 1 upon n e5
right let's put it on the board see if
we missed something
so we saw B v e5 captures captures
captures
and yeah okay so the Rick is hanging so
you're correct so I miscalculated this
line so let's look at let's look at B 5
e 5 I yes okay so probably the Bishop's
hanging right so we have to play this
and so it looks as though you know black
is coming out on top in the end yeah so
okay let's move on so yeah II 5 is an
interesting idea but actually I think
you know since a 5 we've calculated now
doesn't work I think B 5 is actually
just a good move because is this trade
something white wants to happen or
something white would like to avoid if
possible
does white want to take on b5 and have a
takes b5 happen or is that something
white wants to avoid so okay but I'm
saying in general is C takes b5
something white wants to happen or is
that something white would rather have
white would rather avoid that exchange
yeah that's right
white would definitely want to avoid
this if possible because you know
there's no need for white to try to
activate this rook and there's something
else that's a little bit more important
than even just activating the rook that
a C takes b5 yes so see b5 removes a
defender of this critical d5 square so
blacks only weakness in the position is
now it's a lot more free to play d5
later on if the C pawn ever gets removed
so with that of mines white would
probably want to play a bishop you - I'm
sorry sir can you please can you please
stop interrupting so much I'm sorry okay
so with that in mind let's look at
Bishop b2 so this prevents white from
opening up the you know prevents or this
gives white another option besides
opening up the a file as you said you
can't play some nonchalant move because
b4 would be a fork which is why we come
to this Bishop b2 move stepping out of
the fork but now what can black do to
try and force the issue here how can you
try and force White's hand into opening
up this a file and removing the the c-4
defender
any ideas
yes so Rick see it is a great idea so
you simply want to add another attacker
to this pawn and then that might force
the issue in force white to respond to
it because right now of course white
wouldn't be able to take back with the
b-pawn right because of this bishop
hanging on b2 so if we add another
attacker and let's say I don't know
nothing happens then we actually are
threatening to win this pawn here
because of course at the end of the day
this Bishop is gonna be hanging on b2
but you know there's actually better
move than Dirk to c8 because we do want
this a file to open but in the end we
would love if we could keep our rook on
this a file to make use of it so some
other way to add an attacker to c4
definitely on the right track with York
to c8 there's just a slightly better way
to make this work
Queen b6 is pretty interesting one thing
you got to be careful of though is it's
a lot like the relationship of the
bishops on b7 and g2 is these queens are
kind of staring each other down through
this pawn and so if this Queen were to
step away you've always got to be
careful I know the stork is hanging
right now but you've got to be careful
of these five tactics now they kind of I
this lonely rook on a so we looked at
Rick c8 and Queen b6 was interesting but
we'd love to we really need to keep
challenging this diagonal some other way
to add an attacker here yeah yeah Rick
c7 is totally right and Rick c7 would
actually I think force white to take on
b5 I don't think there's any other real
way for a white to handle this you could
try something like Knight to e2 but at
this point you're really kind of running
backwards and now I think there are
there might be some interesting tactics
here let's see I'm trying to think
myself now but maybe uh you know we can
remove a defender somehow
so nice to see through of course the
idea is to add a defender to c4 but it
actually removes the defender of another
keep on
tonight serve an important role in c3
yeah
yes oe5 and of course this is forcing
the rook away maybe there comes back to
be two or D - I think controlling this
important score on b2 and now of course
this removes the defender of e4 so that
was really the only way I think for
white to naturally add a defender to the
c-4 square so he would be forced to
capture now and now with the opening of
this a file White has to be really
really careful because if he's not
careful I think black is simply better
in this position and the reason for that
is okay black has this weakness on d6
but it's well defended and now all the
sudden blacks pieces all are serving
important purposes right this Knight in
this queen are both eyeing the c4 pawn
this rook is eyeing this week' to pawn
and this work is challenging an open
file while this bishop might not look
great it's actually serving a very very
important role it's kind of preventing
all counter play because the only source
of counter plant for white here is
really against this d6 pawn and with
this Bishop alive there's no way for
white to really try to break through
with that immense white can actually I
think maintain the balance here with
something like rook to be for gaining
some time on this B pawn so white would
actually like would actually be forced
to do an interesting exchange sacrifice
and maybe this is what drove a Jannik
away from this line in the game because
he actually didn't play b5 because other
than that it's kind of unclear how black
is going to hold on to this pawn and
place some strange-looking move like
Kirk a5 but now actually there's a pin
here and how can white add more pressure
to the pin
yeah simply a four and now there's
there's no way for a black to really
hold on here um so with that of Mines
that's why you know Rick takes c3 would
be forced here but now the big idea is
finally we make use of this discovered
attack and as well as this freeing idea
of d5 it's the common freeing idea in
the Hedgehog and black would find
equality again so definitely be Phi
would be an interesting choice with that
in mind though you know there's
definitely a lot going on there with
this route before move and Yannick just
shows to play d5 instead which is also
you know the other classic freeing move
is another great way to open up your
pieces open up this bishop open up this
rook but there's a lot of tactics behind
it and that's where being a 2600 versus
a 2800 comes into play is you're able to
calculate these kinds of things no this
was a standard time control game yeah
the rapid the rapid event is what's
going on now that's what Magnus is
playing in and of course we're looking
at our wonderful commentators in their
games so we saw a d5 and a lot of things
are going on one thing is that this
bishop is attacked and that's something
that white kind of has to answer
immediately so with that in mind we saw
Bishop takes f8 and white doesn't really
have any other choice here you have to
do things with tempo and this solves the
problem with the bishop with tempo and
now we can kind of see the point of
blacks play because if black were to
simply recapture here and with something
like the rook what's going to happen
it's a simple counting puzzle one
defender two defender three defender
four defender one attacker two attacker
three attacker four attacker five
attackers so black will lose upon
counting to five it's difficult stuff
but thankfully both of these players
knew how to do it so black has to do
something a little bit more clever here
than recapturing I think you guys should
be able to find it
it's an in-between move move in between
the capture
and it is
yep
so that's exactly right do you take c4
and now even more pieces are hanging and
the complications are kind of
multiplying of course why doesn't have
time to save this bishop for a variety
of reasons now the main one being this
queen is hanging and as well as this
rook is hanging so your next guess might
be okay I want to save this Queen so I
want to take this con as well so what
happens if i take this pawn well then
you run into the fact that this rook is
hanging so the only way to really solve
all these problems you might think is to
take on d7 and okay my queen singing but
your queen is also hanging but
unfortunately yours is hanging with
check so none of these options white
really has which is why he and ended up
coming up with the move of Knight takes
e4 which would you know in theory Alaric
takes d4 but you know White has a nice
idea afterwards so what's stopping or
takes d4
yes so the hanging Queen so what moves
specifically yeah so Knight takes f6
runs into Queen takes b7 afterwards of
course so Rick takes d4 at f6 is with
check so no time to insert Queen takes
f3 and then you would lose the Queen so
because of this you can accept out of
the check with King takes f8 and now the
complications are kind of over this work
is still hanging white does something
with it he takes on d7 and we saw neck
takes d7 in order to preserve the pawn
structure so that you know black
wouldn't have to recapture with the Jeep
on there and now we kind of just see
some position here it looks like we're
nearing an end game there are still
Queens on the board so it can be
dangerous but all in all neither player
he really was able to prove anything
right you can say b6 is kind of a
weakness but there's no way for white to
attack it and on the other side white
doesn't really have any targets either
so that's why this position is equal as
most Grandmaster games end up being but
as you can see something changed later
on cuz he annek won this game so let's
skip ahead a little bit why it tried to
break through right away to c5 he sensed
that you know the game was dwindling out
so he tried to open it up right away I
always saw B takes d5 Knight c5 black
jumped at the opportunity to trade these
Queens because this King is probably a
little bit more unsafe on f8 so we saw
the Queen trade and then uh two options
here for black he could take on c5 or he
could move his Knight away either one is
really okay but Anik thought he had
better chances to hold I think with the
knight on the board seeing is how it has
a very natural square where it controls
a lot of important things we saw King e4
Kings are very important in the endgame
so we call Saul King e7 just activating
f4 a5 93-95 like I said a very natural
square and it controls important scores
in your own camp as well as important
squares in the enemy camp
oh yeah oh yes so here so that would
have been totally possible I think
unfortunately I don't think there's
actually a threat so well I could do
white can do a couple things here maybe
b4 was something Yannick was actually
worried about and that's why you played
a five so quickly simply defending the
knight and in the case of something like
this maybe you can play a five here and
get away with it but maybe actually a
this pawn is is capturable and so yeah
there's just unfortunately no threat
pins are nice but can't always make use
of them so we saw a5 trying to hamper
white spawns more moves were played the
Kings came closer to the center and none
of this really changed the evaluation of
the position white managed to play b4
which gives them the past pawn but you
know it's not going to be enough to win
the game or anything
we saw Knight a5 king of c3a before king
before white poked around on the Kings
side and now you know black clearly has
this this pawn well under control but
three pieces controlling a five more
maneuvering happens and now let's see
here
Magnus made a critical mistake so I've
talked and talked and talked about how
loose pieces fall into tactics so Magnus
has a loose piece here and he has a
loose piece here and unfortunately he
made a mistake he could have done a
number of things to not lose this game
instead he chose to play rook to g8
attacking a jeep on and of course this
allows a tactic so I'm curious if you
guys are good enough to beat Magnus
Carlsen you good enough to find the move
that defeated Magnus Carlsen in this
game
I think you might be you might just be
good enough so again how do we find
tactics we simply look at the loose
pieces and see how we can take advantage
of it
so lose pieces
the night yes so we've got this night
and we got this rook
both are undefended how do we attack
both yeah any idea yes simply 97 is
winning the game that's right
so congratulations I'm naming you all
honorary magnus carlsen the feeders
because you attacks two things at the
same time and you can't defend both of
them
Magnus try drift to g7 which you know is
a hitting this night but unfortunately
for him
rook takes d3 comes with check and this
game was over afterwards
Magnus continued on for a little bit
Yannick simply used his extra piece to
start picking up some of these pawns and
here you know after this move preventing
this fork this pawn is hanging this pawn
is hanging everything will will continue
to fall and Magnus is actually resigned
here so a pretty impressive showing from
Yannick who is in st. Louis right now
doing commentary for us so we're very
happy to have such a talented player
here who managed to take down Magnus and
lessons to be learned from this game
what did you guys pick up from it there
are a lot of stuffs that we we talked
about and you know was mentioned that it
can be kind of tough to try and find
things that relate to your own games
from games of players with such a high
level but there's definitely stuff there
if you're looking for it so what do you
think what did we wear we talked about
yeah so the relationship between the
bishops early on in the opening let's
make my way back there
so yeah this relationship which usually
tends to favor white which is why we saw
I think a little bit later on this d6
move instead of d5 so it's okay to go in
for this relationship but you do just
have to be careful
later on we talked about you know what
white gave up we could move like d4 he
gave up his strong LightSquared bishop
for blacks LightSquared bishop but in
exchange he got this central space and
then we saw that you know black didn't
do anything special he played for the
simple plans that he knew should be
correct
and Magnus wasn't able to prove anything
because you know believe it or not
Magnus isn't magic he can only take what
you give him and so that's the same with
any chess player and so if you follow
simple principles played towards the the
natural plans you're good to go and then
later on he did get a bit lucky
Magnus did just hang a tactic but you
have anybody has to get lucky if you're
playing Magnus Carlsen and you want to
beat him so with that in mind I think
we've given you Annika spotlight for
maybe a little bit too long let's take a
look at our two other main commentators
which are Alejandra Ramirez a st. Louis
local now he works a lot with the slew
chess team and Tanja Sukhdev who is an
Indian international master and so this
was a game they actually played with
each other believe it or not and they
played two games with each other and I
should mention that Alejandro has won
one of them but today we're going to be
giving Tania the spotlight and looking
at her game which she managed to defeat
Alejandro and so it was another game
that began with c4 this time I moved to
rather than move one we saw six g3 and
in this case rather than you know going
for some Bishop a relationship like this
train defi and Catalan on the Queen side
well I simply took this pawn on c4
saying thanks for the pond I will take
it let me hide the notation here so we
saw Queen a for regaining the pawn
Knight to d7 and queen takes e4 black
followed up with a six and this is just
common opening ideas so we can see the
point in a moment black played a 6 for
b5 here
trying to take advantage of the
placement of this Queen to gain some
space on the Queen side so once again we
find this relationship so once again
black is going to have to be slightly
careful to not fall into anything where
white can take advantage of it White
Castle black develops white went for an
early a4 trying to make use of blacks
kind of loose Queen side right this
bishops undefended this pawns only
defended once maybe white can try to go
for something with
of this a file we saw c5 expanding
further and so one big advantage of
expanding is you have more space for
your pieces and so c5 is actually I
think aimed a few things the obvious is
it controls these advanced squares and
prevents maybe white from going for
something like d4 or b4 right away but
the other thing is it gives white or
gives black an important square for one
of her pieces and so what squared do you
think she can use to kind of hold
together her Queen side now because if
you look it's all a little bit loose
these three pieces in particular are
going to be a little bit loose if black
doesn't find a way to kind of hold it
together so what do we think
what outposts kind of near a near home
here look good for blacks pieces
yeah that's right
c5 gives black this option to play Queen
b6 which is going to be very nice square
for the Queen
controlling b5 you know supporting any
eventual advance of the pawns even
controlling d4 indirectly and giving
this bishop another defender which is
something black really likes to do
because like I said the main advantage
for white is that this bishop is always
going to be defended and this bishop
usually isn't
and so Queen b6 you know knowing this
kind of specifics of this relationship
between the bishops usually helps black
out we saw Knight to c3 and indeed black
plays Queen to b6 adding the fender here
a defender here as we were talking about
we saw d3 Bishop e7 getting developed
8xb a takes B rook takes Bishop tix and
Queen b3 adding yet another attacker to
this pawn but fortunately black knew
better than to worry about it and played
Knight to d5 so this is kind of a
tactical way to defend the pawn
certainly black could have actually
played something like Bishop to c6 and I
think this would have been fine for
black just defending the pawn through
natural means but 95 is an interesting
way to go about it so of course what
happens if Queen takes b5
yeah Knight c3 and what if Queen takes
b6 yeah we have this nice in-between
move with checks so Knight c3 pardon me
Queen b6 and I take C 2 with check so
well black would pick up the pawn here
or actually I guess it'd still be even
material but it definitely would be more
favorable for black and next question
what if Knight takes d5 what do we have
here for black
yeah Bishop c6 that's right simply using
this pin to our advantage
there's no Knight to d4 because of pawn
takes and her queen is defended and
white would have some tricky stuff here
after something like efore trying to you
know shift the schneider rounds and
something like e 5 but the complications
work out for black which you know Tonya
I'm sure calculated in the game so we
saw Knight to d5
efore was played immediately trying to
you know take away this knight takes c3
option allowing Queen takes b5 in the
game black actually chose Knight to be 4
so this kind of defends the pawn by
interfering with the Queen as well as
putting pressure here so white simply
played Knight to e2 defending the d3
pawn black got castled and we saw Bishop
e3 so I'd say we're out of the opening
now now the black got castled so let's
kind of take stock of what's going on
here
what both players are kind of playing
for it's less clear than then in the
last position I think so in general what
do you think White's ideas are going to
be
how can he use his pieces best
yeah yeah he's he's built up a bit of a
fortress around this King but that's not
enough to win chess game I've got a go
on the attack a little bit so what
targets might white try to find here
what a kind of weak spots that has black
made there's a few things to look out
for sure something like d4 could come
later on advancing in the center and
certainly maybe later an e5 move would
open up this bishop although it is still
kind of challenged by this black bishop
on a but something I like to do when I'm
not sure if what's going on in a
position is look at the pawn structure
and look at weaknesses so black actually
has a couple big weaknesses here which
are b5 and c5 so I think that white is
probably going to be playing largely
around these two pawns
if white can find a way to put up
meaningful pressure on these pawns it's
going to be good for him because then
blacks pieces are going to be tied down
to defending these things and then maybe
white can think about these other ideas
maybe even expanding with an f4 move and
an e5 move and maybe a d4 move as well
so White's definitely going to want to
put pressure on these pawns conversely
you know black hasn't pushed these pawns
forward for nothing and something
typical of this pawn structure is you
know these pawns are right next to each
other and that means they're in kind of
the perfect place to start advancing so
blacks ideas usually are going to be to
try to advance these pawns grab even
more space and find more you know
outposts for his pieces are for her
pieces in this case so she's already
found this outpost on b4 and maybe if
she can push to c4 she can actually look
at squares even further in White's camp
and try to use that to her advantage in
this game and so let's see how those
players kind of put those ideas into
action
we saw Queen to a6 so you know black
takes the time to step out of this pin
on the Queen
rook to d1 so you know why it was taking
your advice here kind of aiming at this
d4 push we saw Bishop to c6 so black is
simply you know supporting these two
pawns and preparing for an adventure
advance
Knight to e1 opening up this Bishop and
c4
so black actually does break through
first white wasn't really able to put up
that pressure so black I was able to
break through saw D takes d4 and B takes
c4 and Queen to c3 and so what do we
thinks going on now because every time
pawns are kind of exchanged or moved
that's a change in structure and it's a
good time to try to reevaluate the
position and so who do we think is
better here who would you rather be it's
kind of tough with so many pieces on the
board with so much going on but it's
important to try and develop the skill
where you can say okay am I better here
am i worse here
what are both sides doing
so let's just take a show of hands who
would rather be white you two okay who
would rather be black Ryan would rather
be black who has no idea what's going on
okay all right so you think you think
it's about equal then right you're not
so sure so two for white one for black
and so any justification for why you
took that stance Ryan why do you or yes
sure let's start with you why do you
prefer white yet so it seems like this
one might be a target sure
sure so you might be able to get rid of
this night on b4 which is you know
blacks kind of most advanced piece his
best piece or her best piece so yeah
that's some definitely good points so
this point on c4 might become a little
weight weak and thus nighttime before
might get kicked around but conversely
what does black kind of have going for
what are her advantages Ryan since you
picked black so more space it's kind of
a general term but more importantly she
can kind of use this space right so how
can she use the space to her advantage
some specific squares that might come in
handy maybe yeah so this D 3 square so
the idea of kicking this night out with
something like night 2 C 2 was mentioned
but you know as soon as this night
leaves a1 suddenly 93 becomes an option
so it's something white has to be
careful of and of course tonight C 2 it
might be an idea but white might want to
defend this D 3 square first as well as
that there are other squares right this
B 3 square maybe we can see you know for
example maybe a bishop we're aiming its
way into this square making something
like night to see 2 even harder and as
well as C 4 possibly becoming a target B
2 is also you know not not so safe we
can put a rock on this open file or half
open file and if this night does get to
D 3 B 2 might come under fire so I would
definitely prefer black here and the
reason I prefer blacks kind of
advantages to whites advantages are if I
had the white pieces I would really be
scared of this be pawn compared to the C
pawn so with Wyatt I would be trying to
play b3 to trade off these two pieces
and then I would hope I'm equal
basically and so it's just a matter of
experience and looking at specifics of
the position is is how you can kind of
start to judge these things so I think
b2 is a little bit more weak than c4 and
so that's why I would prefer black here
let's see what happened now we saw at
Knight to f6 stepping off of this open
file putting some pressure on White's
Center as well
we saw f3 defending and now Knight to a2
an interesting way of trying to dislodge
the white pieces Queen did ie 5 of
course Queen to c2 isn't really possible
because of this Bishop a4 move so I saw
Queen to e5 advancing and now Queen to
b7
putting more pressure on this efore pawn
if this F pawn ever dreams of moving and
putting pressure on this week BT upon
like like I was saying we saw Knight to
e4 an interesting idea here so this is
where tactics kind of start to fly again
and this is where kind of Alejandro
maybe got out calculated or
got a little bit unlucky because this
line is so long and complicated that I
don't think either player really could
have had a perfect understanding of what
was going on but of course what is
Knight d4 daring black to do and saying
I dare you to take this because I don't
think it works out for you
so yeah that's right it's daring black
to take on b2 of course you don't want
to do it right away because this Bishop
is singing so it's kind of daring black
to play Bishop a4 where after this rook
moves then maybe you're able to take
this pawn on b2 and so something like
rook to be one might not be great for a
couple of reasons I want to say c3 is
the main reason why it might not be so
great taking advantage of this pin
something like Kirk to d2 I'm gonna be
honest I didn't fully consider but
looking off the top of my head I think
just something like Bishop before it
might be good which is how white came up
with a move rook to a1 here trying to
defend this pawn by attacking this night
basically of course no black actually
accepts the challenge takes this pawn on
b2 and the only way from white to really
hold things together here is with this
knight c6 idea and of course the circ is
hanging you don't you actually can't
really move it anywhere so you have to
try to defend it with something like
Knight to c6 taking advantage of blacks
loose Queen so we saw excuse me a queen
takes e5 and I take c5 Bishop b3 Knight
to c6
this was actually White's idea I think
so White's saw this idea coming from
from a while back white noticed that ok
this Bishop is actually pretty short on
squares King well I guess it can go to
d8 but it's not something it really
wants to do it actually can't go to d6
because of e5 forking the pieces can't
go to c5 it can't go to b4 I guess it
has to go to a3 and then White's next
idea was this night c2 move trying to
make use of this overworked piece so of
course black can't take cuz rook a 2 is
the now actually a fork which is kind of
crazy kind of a crazy line but black
came up with a another natural move just
Bishop b2 and after rook to b1 this is
where this is where it kind of got even
more crazy so what's an interesting way
to kind of keep things going for black
here
you don't really want to just move this
bishop out of the way and that's my
hints to you you don't really want to
just move this bishop out of the way
sure so that's an interesting idea is
counter-attacking something else while
your piece is hanging
fortunately this this fall is to attack
take care of the check
attacking both king and rook c3 that's
an interesting move actually I honestly
have no idea this is so complicated
possibly a night six to d4 move might be
okay for a for white here maybe even to
be four but I'm gonna stick with with d4
for the moment maybe you have to move
this piece out of the way and now let's
see what we can do here this actually
looks okay but something must be wrong
with it
something must be wrong
I honestly don't know let's see what the
computer says
so this night to d4 maybe Bishop a4 and
just something like Bishop f1 and okay
maybe white is is trying to hold on but
this would actually be better for black
so perhaps to Ryan who just exited on
finding this idea Ryan's back alright
okay I just revealed the solution
anyways CS III was actually interesting
black is actually a little bit better
after C three in the game Tom you played
the much more crazy night to sue okay
that would be that would be impressive
but she played the much crazier Knight
to c3 forcing the Circa actually to take
this bishop with the idea of having this
fork on d1 next not a fork you really
see everyday in the game you can't
really try to just save this rook
because this Bishop takes C 2 followed
by 93 and if you just tried to defend
this rook unfortunately this nights
hanging at the end so it's quite
interesting in the game Alejandra
actually came up with rook to be one
allowing Bishop c2 and now after rook to
c1 simply a knight takes III and all of
a sudden it is black who's up a piece
for the moment whereas you know black
started off sacrificing a piece with
Knight c3 and you know white is actually
just totally lost here
after King to f2 maybe this was his idea
trying to remove the defender but
there's a knight d1 check and a Bishop
b3 and black is just barely managing to
keep all all her pieces together we saw
night 2 B 2 and this is where white
realized okay there's no way to win my
piece back and he resigned here and so
big win for Tanya big win for Tanya and
so although you might not have been able
to follow all the crazy tactics as I was
also not able to follow them completely
without you know spending a lot of time
analyzing the position but there's still
you know stuff you can learn from these
games and hopefully you know a little
bit more about our great commentary team
here for a
a bezel on the Ivory Coast so any
questions about this game any questions
I've got a pretty good idea of what went
on except maybe for all these tactics
which I don't know if I could explain
given three hours rather than the one
I'm allotted just to do a quick recap of
what what happened here so we saw this
b5 move and c5 and so understanding
again this relationship between the
bishops c5 is doing a lot it's grabbing
Moors queenside space but it's also
preparing to kind of hold your position
together which is always important and
the other big thing we looked at here is
trying to evaluate a complicated
position which can be difficult but it's
not as difficult as you might think if
you try to break it down to its kind of
essential elements
yes Black has more queenside space and
yes Black has a weakness on c4 white has
less space and a weakness on b2 and it's
all about who can kind of take advantage
of it the most and so in this case it
turned out to be the player with the
black pieces Tania SEC t'v with that of
Mines thank you guys for coming out
thank you guys for watching on YouTube I
hope you enjoyed this iteration of the
road to 2000
[Music]
you